hi everyone my name is robert hackett
and i'm a senior writer and tech editor
at fortune
today we're going to be talking about
some sciency stuff
this is an issue briefing hosted by the
world economic forum that's themed
what's next for quantum computing
we've assembled some leading experts
here to talk about that with us
here today are daario gill the head of
ibm research the unit that cooks up big
blue's most cutting-edge tech
we have franka hyman who is the founding
director at quantum delta nl which
stands for netherlands and she is
helping to set the national quantum
policy for the netherlands
we also have john preskill a caltech
professor who is one of the world's
leading quantum scientists he's also
advising amazon on its quantum strategy
and finally we have jeremy jergens the
managing director of the world economic
forum center for the fourth industrial
revolution which looks at all the ways
tech is reshaping our world
let's dive right in
i'm gonna go out on a limb and
assume that most people tuning in here
are familiar with computers they likely
own their own and are probably using one
to watch this session right now
um but today we're gonna be talking
about a different kind of computer a
quantum computer
john i'd love if you could kick us off
by telling us how is a quantum computer
different from a regular computer
well when many particles interact with
one another according to the principles
of quantum mechanics then it turns out
it's extraordinarily complex to describe
what those particles are doing
using ordinary language or
our classical computers
and so if we can
control how those particles interact
then we should be able to perform
information processing tests that
wouldn't otherwise be possible
we still have a limited understanding
though of what are the application areas
in which quantum computers will have a
big advantage
as far as we can currently foresee
the most important application areas
will be understanding how matter behaves
with applications to chemistry and the
discovery of materials and so on and
that will benefit society eventually in
many ways through advances in medicine
and energy production and
other areas
but
it's still highly uncertain how long
it's going to take to scale up the
quantum computing technology we have now
so that we can run those applications
it's not that we understand all the
science now and we just need to put the
resources together to do the engineering
we're going to need a lot of innovation
to get to quantum computers that can
solve
those very impactful problems
that's a great point there is going to
be a lot of innovation that's involved
uh a lot of hard work a lot of
engineering a lot of science
breakthroughs to come uh
let's pivot to dario uh given the fact
that you are so avidly working on
building some of these machines of the
future
dario where do we stand right now
with the state of quantum computing what
is available and where are we headed
next
yeah one way to
look at the current situation is you
have to think
about how to execute a roadmap from
current capability to the very future
that john was speaking about
so what we have witnessed
about five years ago
we were able to build a small uh
you know quantum
computer and make it universally
available through the cloud
and uh so that kicked off a journey
where we started exposing to a growing
community around the world these
concepts of quantum information
science and quantum information
processing and ways with which we could
interact with this novel form of
computation
and i'm bringing a community along so
where have we come in the last five
years so since we put that first system
up
we built over 30 different kinds of
quantum computers that we've made
available over 20 of them are available
uh today
uh
if you go to uh you know ibm quantum
and uh just to give you a sense of how
the community has grown
uh
close to two billion quantum circuits
are run every single day these are like
the instruction sets that allows us to
create these superposition interference
and entanglement steps that happens
inside the quantum computer and as a
consequence of all of this what we're
starting to see
is
a broad set of institutions
getting interested on the topic starting
to form small teams to learn what the
use cases
may be there develop skills get access
to the technology
and the philosophy i think we have is we
got to deliver every year better and
better quantum computers and quantum
systems that ultimately arise a promise
but i think it's very important to build
to bring people along in the journey
rather than saying it one day there'll
be a magical computer that does all
these things is let's come together and
work through it together as we go and
execute every year
you mentioned this roadmap and i'd
imagine there is a lot of planning that
needs to go into this into mapping out
the timeline over many many years
um but maybe you can tell us what that
roadmap looks like
and where you hope to get in say
three five ten years from now
yeah there are different ways to build
quantum computers in ibm we use uh
superconducting
technology uh at present uh if you look
at from a number of qubit perspectives
the largest systems that we deploy are
65 qubits this year we're gonna
uh deliver uh
the first machine that breaks the 100
cubit barrier and then um in 2023 i mean
2022 we're gonna have a system with over
400 and by 2023 we will build a machine
with over a thousand qubits
uh and you know i'm summarizing just
saying the number of qubits but behind
the scene there's just so many things
that you gotta get right in terms of the
quality of the qubits the control
electronics how you program the
environments and so on but yes we think
2023 we will build a machine with over a
thousand qubits and then that very
importantly and the dimension that is
important after that to build machines
with tens of thousands or even hundreds
of thousands of qubits is that you build
a scalable modular architecture that
allows you to continue to scale but it
gives you a sense of how much things
were progressing right five years ago
five qubits by 2023 a machine with over
a thousand
so over a thousand qubits and ibm has
actually been one of the uh
the leaders in the industry who has been
pushing to move away from kind of
measuring these machines based on qubits
entirely and to use other sorts of
metrics that factor in their error rates
um because these machines tend to have a
lot of errors involved and uh and so i i
wonder how error prone the machines will
be that you mentioned uh will have a
thousand qubits in 2023
yeah that's exactly right so so
you know when you build one of these uh
systems the connectivity and the errors
are present
on the qubits limit the performance how
long uh you know and how long you can
run the calculation you know and the
fidelity that you can achieve with them
so uh there's metrics like you know we
introduced in the past like quantum
volume right that give you uh an
expression of the kind of performance
and capability of the machines
and that one is indeed related to to
their rate um the speed of the quantum
processor is extremely important right
to run any kind of practical
applications you often have to run
hundreds of thousands if not a billion
quantum circuits uh repeatedly so that's
one of the reasons why we like
superconducting technology so much
compared to let's say ions as an example
because it does offer superior speed
performance but you're right so is is
the capacity of the machine how many
circuits you can run the quality with
which you can run these circuits all of
those are extraordinarily important and
just qubits alone doesn't tell you the
power of a quantum computer
got it and we'll get into that a little
bit more um but i want to pass the ball
over to fraka uh because we've talked a
little bit about the road map for
achieving usable useful quantum
computers uh within a big company uh
context but you are actually helping set
the national agenda for a whole country
um so tell us what sorts of factors come
into play when you are setting the
national strategy uh for a country uh to
get into quantum computing and to to
lead
yeah yeah what we are looking at is not
only the technological roadmap uh but uh
ecosystem approach so we are also
looking at how do you get the right
talent uh how do you educate the right
people to move into this field how do
you make sure
new companies can start so from the lab
in the academic labs there's also the
opportunity to start a company there's
enough capital there to invest in these
startups
to attract also companies for instance
like ibm amazon or microsoft to invest
in europe to be part of the ecosystem as
well because we believe and it was also
already mentioned we still have a long
road ahead of us and
it's just still time to make sure a lot
of science is done innovation is done
and that needs a broad ecosystem to
develop and netherlands is a small
country
but we are also working very closely in
the european context for instance we
just signed an mou with the french
because also in france there's a
national strategy and
yeah we just would like to see as much
openness in the ecosystem as possible so
that people can connect build new
technology together
uh and you said you signed an agreement
with the french government and mou what
is that and and what does that mean
an mou is a memorandum of understanding
it's sort of an intention the french
also just like us
the national agenda a year ago they also
want to invest a big
chunk of government funding into this
field and to make sure that
it's not the french doing this
and the netherlands is doing that and
there's no way to connect to each other
but our labs can work together we have
signed this memorandum of understanding
and
also to make sure it's not only
high-level policy or politics it's also
about concrete actions we launched uh
job board so there's a website with
where you can find all the jobs that are
in the netherlands and in french at all
the companies and universities if you
want to be active in this
challenging field
so you're cooperating with various
governments how cooperative do you find
this field of quantum computing to be
how cooperative versus competitive is it
yeah this is a very almost philosophical
question i would say it's it's
competitive science is competitive and
also of course companies are competitive
but there's also because it's still in
its early days and it's still a lot
about science and ideas and trying new
things there's also a lot of uh
collaboration and an exchange of people
it's still a rather small few people
know each other
some people who graduate with maybe at
john frasco's
lab now are in in in in the big company
elsewhere so it's also there's a lot of
exchange of people and ideas and
and to me yeah that's my pers i i
strongly believe in collaboration so my
pitch is to work more together and
break down barriers between institutions
uh i'll turn it over to jeremy in just a
second but while we're on the subject of
cooperative versus collaborative uh or
versus competitive um i figured i'd also
ask you know john as somebody who
recently joined amazon
and as somebody who spent a long
distinguished tenured career as a
scientist as well uh whether you are
encountering any tensions when it comes
to sort of
uh you know what remains proprietary
within a big company and the sort of
open
publishing atmosphere that
governs science
well
i think
we all have the same goals for the time
being the companies and in academia
we all want to get closer to the day
when we can run applications which will
deliver
value
to customers
and it's a long road to get there as
came up in in dario's remarks we have
quantum computers now
with uh
over 60 qubits but they're rather poor
quality qubits when we perform
operations on
pairs of the qubits
they often make errors nearly one time
out of 100 there's an error and that's a
severe
limitation
on the size of the applications we can
run for now
so we're all looking forward to much
better performance
which we're hoping to achieve both
through improvement in the hardware and
through software
methods for mitigating the imperfections
of the hardware and we'll probably have
to do both and success in that direction
is going to benefit everybody in the
industry and in quantum science so i
think we're all rooting for one another
in that sense
we all want to see those innovations
happen and that'll bring us closer to
the day
when uh quantum computing can have a
broad impact on humanity and that's what
we all want to see so i think there is
from that point of view a kind of spirit
of cooperation
uh at least for now within the industry
and within the broader quantum community
arya would you agree with that
completely i look i think one of the
things that unites all of us is we want
to see a quantum industry
uh thrive and be successful
we each
place our bets
form our teams and push our boundaries
and push our frontiers forward but we're
absolutely united in in the appetite to
hey make a convincing argument which
we've done in the past in different
governments to invest in quantum
information science we saw the example
in the united states of the national
quantum initiative
we're just talking examples of what's
happening in europe you see it in japan
and so on and we advocate for those
investments that's a good thing right
it's an exciting endeavor you train
students you do fantastic research and
then we're also seeing within a more
sort of commercial setting uh lots of
companies big and small you know
including venture capital placing bets
and taking risks and exploring new
opportunities and i do think that
there's a cooperative atmosphere from
the perspective of
wishing the industry success and growing
the industry
now we also compete uh as uh we should
uh on the specific approaches that we
take within it what kinds of machines we
do it like how you do it like an
ecosystems around it but um but i i
would still say it's a very sort of like
positive environment where we joined
forces to uh to you know create a new
industry frankly what's exciting about
it this hasn't happened in many decades
right a whole entire new approach to
computation at this scale and i think
we're all feel excited about the
historical moment that we're witnessing
uh let's drill down on that historical
moment i'm gonna uh get jeremy involved
now uh you know jeremy
given your role sitting within the world
economic forum you are studying all of
these big tech changes and how they're
transforming the world in which we live
um maybe you could contextualize for us
uh what is happening within quantum
computing why it's so exciting and how
that kind of fits with some of the other
big trends out there you know whether
it's uh you know happenings in cyber
security or uh
digital currency
and and everything in between
great thank you thank you for that
robert um no this is extremely exciting
and i have to say among all the
different technologies we cover
quantum is definitely in the top three
and you know a number of the
contributors here today
showcased the extent to which the road
ahead of us is uncertain you know and
we're in an era of a lot of quantum hype
uh there's a lot of money in the market
these days chasing different promises
and contributions here but what we see
is that the journey will take us longer
and i believe it's roy amara who said
you know we have a tendency to
overestimate the effects of technology
in the near term and underestimate them
in the longer term
and if you think about quantum in this
context and you think back to
you know the last major paradigm you
know shifts in computing we're talking
about room-sized computers and no one
would ever imagine that you would be
having a super computer in your pocket
as it may be
now you know i'm not sure how close we
are to having super computers uh quantum
computers that have to be near absolute
zero
carried around our pop
pockets there but it is hard for us to
understand how this will play out and
that's one of the reasons why we need to
bring all the actors together here
in this listen we've established the
quantum computing network and so we're
happy to have the participation of
amazon of ibm of microsoft a number of
academic institutions and also national
governments
all working with us to explore what are
the implications here and it won't be
done on technology alone right the
technology is absolutely critically
important there's different uh you know
beliefs on how that might evolve
what may emerge there even people
looking at doing quantum computing on a
chip
so there's a lot of different approaches
we're not here to try and pick the
winners what we are here to try and do
is understand what are the skills we
need
how do we make sure that the benefits
from quantum can be extended across
society and that they're being put to
the most significant applications
and also how do we manage to secure
uh the transition there right and in
this sense
most of the computing infrastructures
that we have today
are not quantum secure
the road map of win
you know you'll be in a situation that
you might be able to break uh some of
the current encryption with a quantum
computer is unknown
but that day is coming right so we need
to both harness the opportunities in
front of us whether it's in new
materials
in health care or other domains
even as we also manage the risks and
prepare society more broadly for the
significance of this transition ahead of
us
jeremy you said that you would rank
quantum computing in the top three of
big tech changes going on right now what
are the other two just for our uh
yeah you know personally i'm quite keen
on synthetic biology and crispr
you know crispr is less than 10 years
old today and yet we already see
synthetic biology is even newer and then
i think everything around
decarbonization and what we have to do
to be able to sequester carbon it's
going to be a new emerging critical area
that we're still in the early stages of
but will have profound impacts on our
ability to
adapt to the climate challenges
do you expect quantum computing to have
applications in those two other domains
you cited
definitely john highlighted early on you
know some of the applications in
chemistry so to be able to look at a
range of compounds assess their
suitability
in a much more rapid manner and also to
be able to bring forward new materials
right so those materials might be used
in for example renewable sector might be
uh
applied in a desalination of water so
there's any number of different domains
uh that we'd be able to
basically accelerate our understanding
of the uh say fiscal systems with which
we interoperate every day
got it um john when you mentioned
potential applications for quantum
computers you seem to linger on the
scientific pursuits that are almost
basic research and not
not even necessarily making crossing the
chasm over to having useful applications
in industry um
i wonder
whether you believe there is potential
uh
utility there actually within big
commercial operations
or if you're just being cautious in your
framing
of this uh this development
well there are a couple of aspects to
this question
one is
uh how hopeful should we be about using
quantum hardware in the relatively near
term
for running applications of commercial
interest
the quantum computers we have now as
already mentioned are
quite limited but they're sufficiently
powerful now that
they can perform certain tasks which are
beyond the reach of our most powerful
existing supercomputers so we can start
to explore whether they can run
interesting applications and people will
be doing that it's important to do it we
have heuristic ideas
about applications that would be of
interest to customers
but no particularly persuasive argument
that those are going to pan out
in the near term
in the longer term i think the
applications are still
largely unknown as one example there's a
lot of interest for obvious reasons in
the impact quantum computing will have
on artificial intelligence and machine
learning
because we see machine learning already
having a big impact on society and i
think that is an exciting
potential area but as of now we really
don't have any fully
worked out examples where quantum
computing will greatly improve
artificial intelligence tests of the
type that we're running now i think
probably there will be a rich set of
applications coming out of quantum
machine learning as an example
eventually but they'll probably be very
different from applications of machine
learning we see now we probably won't
use quantum computers to drive our cars
or to play go
uh we'll use them in new ways that maybe
we we haven't even anticipated yet
though the most obvious area for quantum
machine learning is the types of
problems that i guess you would call
basic research understanding how quantum
matter behaves but those are problems
which will eventually deliver economic
impact but maybe in the longer term so i
think it's really important to
understand that
we have very limited ability at this
stage to imagine the applications of
quantum computing down the road in the
near term um
i don't think it's particularly likely
that we'll see a lot of economic impact
from running applications on quantum
computing uh quantum computers in the
long run we will and they'll probably be
applications that uh we haven't clearly
understood at this stage
got it
um
dario what applications excite you most
uh that you are hoping come to fruition
yeah i mean i would say that taxonomy
first and foremost is as young correctly
alluded is the application of quantum to
modeling nature on all its form
applications chemistry and materials so
what you're seeing in there for example
in the ibm quantum network we have about
150 institutions uh who are part of the
network and you see large industrial
companies i mean in addition to
universities and national labs but you
will see large industrial companies like
you know daimler and exxon and many
others who
look into the opportunities to develop
team skills methodologies and approaches
to be able to do modeling that they do
today with high performance computing
that they do today with generative
models in ai and begin to understand
what algorithms would be used in that
space so you see that's category number
one right and and i think that will
extend to the life sciences even though
those are more complex molecules etc a
second category is things that have to
do with like linear algebra things of
this work so an underlying
fundamental application on that uh is of
course you know can you apply this to
things like machine learning right as an
example
and i think there's been exciting recent
work on quantum kernels and things you
know that are beginning to provide at
least a hint of the direction that we
may go uh with practical applications
but as john alluded you know there's
ways to go and create a lot of
creativity to happen there and the third
is around the area of like quantum walks
right like traversing graphs or you know
be able to to uh you know explore uh
things that have like a network um sort
of like topology and and to what degree
uh can quantum algorithms help us and i
put them sort of in order of like
hierarchy like a lot more clarity on the
chemistry material science based
interesting and fascinating exploration
machine learning and the third one which
has to compete obviously with the
classical implementations so those are
three areas that i think are the most
exciting and in terms of what industries
i'm seeing like really engaging i would
say industrials
and the other one is financial sector so
you know when i look at jp morgan chase
goldman sachs many others are you know
part of our network and they're very
interested because their relationship
between computation and their business
is quite clear and they're willing to
invest ahead to have the knowledge
skills uh so that when it comes of age
it is ready
so you mentioned investments uh fraca
you are helping to identify and foster
sort of a startup ecosystem around
quantum technology what aspects of the
technology are you looking at what sorts
of businesses are you most intrigued by
and interested in supporting
yeah well we look at the entire stack
but from the public side the most
interest is going into the hardware side
of things things so the deep tech
because they're the capital uh needs the
investment needs of these startups is
fairly high so
uh in in europe we have to do a bit of
effort to make sure that there's enough
venture capital available to fund these
startups and it's really exciting to see
that that's really happening now so we
are
in for instance in the netherlands we
now have around 10 startups which is
fairly small but we aim to have 100 in
the end of the program in seven years
and uh yeah we try to attract the
venture capital also from the us but
also from europe uh with public funds
and then match it in co-funding
constructions with uh private funds and
and you see it happening now and it's
really great to see that these young
people who are have really a tech uh
background uh also getting interested in
entrepreneurship and building a business
and uh getting business cases and that
you know it's a different uh ball game
but uh yeah you see that happening now
it's great
uh what is the biggest threat that you
might identify to quantum computing
you mean as the impact of quantum
computing what could be a threat or the
the threat
well for me the biggest threat
is that
governments and companies uh build walls
to protect their their ip and their
people and that we get in some sort of
lock-in and that the
talent and that the knowledge etc
doesn't flow because i really think it's
important in the years to come that we
need this flow of ideas knowledge and
capital throughout at least i would say
the western world as we call it because
we should work together to yeah make
sure that the promise that this
technology holds will be used for the
good of
of this planet
got it yeah and that is what i meant i i
i'll i'll phrase it better in passing it
over to uh john which is uh
what is the biggest threat to
progress in quantum cuting to actually
uh you know
advancing this technology forward
well i'm not sure i'd call it a threat
but i think it's important to emphasize
that we're still in very early days when
it comes to building quantum hardware
there's been a lot of progress
but it's important for now
to
continue to explore a wide variety of
ways of encoding and processing quantum
information
you know we have a few technologies now
which are the most advanced like using
atoms as qubits or superconducting
circuits
but those like all approaches face big
challenges in scaling up
to the um
applications that will really be
broadly
beneficial
so it's important for
us as a field and as an industry
to keep focused on the long-term goals
because we're going to need much much
better hardware than we have and we
don't know exactly
how that's going to be realized
and let's not uh you know become
overly focused on what we can do in the
next few years as opposed to reaching
the potential of the field in the longer
term
i think we can all appreciate that call
for uh sort of diversification of
avenues and pursuits of research
but i wonder if you had to place all
your chips on the table on a particular
line of inquiry or technology what would
you go for
that's a question for me i guess
yeah well uh
i uh
don't really know nobody really knows uh
what will be the best approach in the
long run uh for now i do like
superconducting circuits but i think we
need to think more broadly about how to
make use of superconducting technology
in quantum computing
we've been using pretty much the same
qubit design for 15 years now what
people call a transmon and it's
continued to improve and ibm has been
responsible for
some of those advances they've got
pretty good trans months now but the
transmon might not be the future of
superconducting quantum computing
because it has intrinsic limitations so
we need to be thinking about if we're
going to use superconducting circuits
different ways of encoding and
processing quantum information using
that those technological tools
dario i ought to give you an opportunity
to respond given that ibm is uh heavily
invested in super conducting qubit
research yeah well that is our bet i
mean you know obviously within a
research organization we also
collaborate with universities and others
to explore different
alternatives and make sure that we're
always grounded and uh and that you know
we continue to validate uh what is the
best path forward and we support very
strongly that there's alternative
approaches and that people invest but
our bed is on super conducting
technology
and um we we don't see
uh any reason we see lots and lots of
things we don't know but we don't see
any reason why we cannot build
uh you know extraordinarily
sophisticated quantum computers using
this technology and uh and we have a
very strong roadmap that uh that we've
laid out and that we continue to exit to
execute on that but i mean advances on
that is going to take everything from
fundamental material sciences
you know the devices themselves the
fabrication techniques how you couple
the qubits the packaging technology the
control electronics the cryogenics the
software stack so so there's a lot of
emphasis sometimes we talk about like
one piece of it but um we build quantum
computers and a computer is a system and
you gotta bring all of these pieces
together you gotta enable that they work
you know now we achieve over 99
uptime reliability in this system which
is kind of remarkable i mean people look
in the field 10 15 years ago people
struggle to maintain you know like that
level of control like you know you have
to have two or three grad students
attached to each experiment almost
and uh and the fact that you can build
machines with that level of stability
right now is remarkable so so yeah lots
of uh challenges and uh that we gotta
execute on the roadmap but i look at the
parallel just to close on semiconduct on
semiconductors too and in semiconductors
it was a very interesting uh sort of
parallel in that we had lots and lots of
challenges and imagining how we would go
and keep scaling things down but it is
the collective mobilization of r d and
the collaboration and competition of a
huge ecosystem that allocates you know
about a hundred billion dollars a year
in r d that overcomes those problems and
challenges and i think that that's what
we need in quantum we need enough scale
that talented people are overcoming all
of these challenges
got it um jeremy i want to ask you as
well what the biggest obstacle is to
achieving progress in quantum computing
before uh ending things off with a sort
of rapid fire uh q a with the the full
panel before we close as we are nearing
the end of our time here today um so
jeremy tell us what is the biggest
obstacle to
progress great
thank you
i think we need patience on this one and
uh dario used the analogy of
semiconductors
we can also look to ai where there was
the ai winter
that you know people speak of in the
1980s uh and you know the deep learning
uh models that are you know
say we're so familiar with today uh that
is scaled up those weren't necessarily
popular at the time right so we don't
necessarily know the model today these
things will take patience you know the
journey is several years out the other
analogy i'd borrow from ai
is that many of our deep learning models
were built on what i would call
fundamentally flawed data sets right
they
the models inherited the biases of the
data sets
and to that end we need to make sure
that when we do design these ecosystems
they're they're not solely technical but
they involve people from academia they
involve you know potential end users and
we have an inclusive ecosystem here and
in that way i think we can avoid
um you know only betting on singular
paths but also uh having the patience to
see something through that's of the
benefit to the wider society at large
excellent
um so before we close out i want to make
sure to just hear from each of our panel
panelists one last time
and the question i'd like answered is
provide us a prediction something
quantifiable something you can put a
number to whether it's a year or some
other sort of measurement aspect
about
what is going to happen in the field of
quantum computing in the years ahead um
some milestone reached perhaps uh you
know a next great big challenge to
overcome
uh
jeremy let's start with you
great well i mean the tough spot here
along with some of these deep quantum
computing experts but you know maybe
being the optimist and after uh
preaching for patients earlier i'd
suggest that we'll see uh
corporations
renting running quantum applications
in parallel to their existing computing
systems
by 2025 that they'll actively be using
them uh to be able to understand what
that growth potential is what some of
the trade-offs are so actually uh i i
see that happening by 2025 uh you know
leveraging uh the resources that are
available by them
that's right around the corner
john let's hear from you
what predictions can you share about
where you think
quantum computing is headed and what
might happen in the years ahead
well from the perspective of quantum
science
we're at kind of a pivotal stage because
we now have
these quantum platforms
that allow us to study
the behavior of many particles
interacting quantum mechanically
in a regime
that has never been experimentally
accessible before
and i think that opens new opportunities
for scientific discovery
so it's my expectation that on a time
scale of about five years
we will be using these quantum platforms
to
give us new insights
into the quantum physics of many
interacting particles by doing
experiments that were never possible
before
now you were uh
a particle physicist before you started
to uh
get more into into quantum science and
became
uh one of the leading lights in that
field uh is there a particular
uh set of experiments or
domain in which you think that uh
quantum will
realize uh some some new fundamental
understanding of the universe
oh well
i'm interpreting that as a question
about the longer term
and i do have what you could call a
dream
which is that with quantum technology we
will be able to do experiments which
will give us insights into the quantum
structure of space-time itself
uh one of the areas which i've been
interested in scientifically is quantum
gravity where quantum physics and
gravitational physics meet this is a
notoriously hard area to study in the
laboratory
but i think with simulations run on
quantum computers we'll be able to
deepen our understanding of that physics
and i think that's an exciting prospect
excellent um i think we're all hoping
for that outcome as well
uh franka give us a prediction or
milestone
i think in
or i hope but i think i expect in
2025 we're past the time of believing
and indicating when and time passed but
then there is a fact there's a actual
application of a quantum computer that
is uh
really faster in real life than any
supercomputer and has commercial or
practical value so we're after posterior
of guessing and believing it's a fact
excellent sounds like 2025 is a popular
year i'm going to mark my calendar uh
dario uh tell us as well give us
something measurable some kind of
quantifiable prediction or milestone you
expect to be achieved in the coming
years
well what uh what we want to deliver is
between this generation of the 100 plus
400 and a thousand qubit which happens
within the next three years i'm going to
go a little bit before then 2025
uh that with those three generations of
systems we demonstrate uh quantum
advantage for applica you know for some
application that that has a path to
practical use
so that would be a good goal and then
i'll give a long-term goal
we just passed
a milestone where a trillion
circuits quantum circuits have been run
on our machines since the last five
years by 2030
um we want that number that uh to be a
trillion quantum circuits a day
that gets run and that those are going
to be the primitives that are going to
be embedded behind
everyday software for classes of
problems that quantums are well-suited
so an exponential growth in terms of
adoption over a decade uh from a
trillion over five years to a trillion a
day
wow trillion today that is a
mind-boggling number um
thank you all to my panelists uh you
know to hit on some of the themes we
touched on today uh it sounds like
everybody is banking on a collaborative
and open sort of uh paradigm for quantum
computing research in the years ahead uh
everybody is hoping that it doesn't get
too competitive and proprietary uh with
people keeping their information siloed
um and
just an incredibly um
exciting array of potential applications
that this this new breakthrough
technology could
help with
um
yeah it is fascinating it's super
exciting to watch and i
cannot thank my panelists enough for
sharing all their expertise and insights
today
thank you all for being here
[Music]
you